being bendy and doing the trapezy thing
was there a moment when i think you you
over exerted yourself it was it in front
of
hugh okay see here's what happened let
me just
clear the air literally so here's the
story literally all right yeah
so we're doing i'm not going to name the
person because
it's embarrassing okay the point is
we're doing a stunt
in front of hugh jackman now i have very
few scenes with hugh jackman
and um i was very i was very nervous it
was not your
and um i was on my you know my a game
because this is hugh jackman
i do not want to mess up so we're doing
this this this this thing where i'm
basically up in the air and i spin down
and i get caught
and i heard a fart
now as a professional i was going to
carry on
it was not me i just want to clarify
right here right now is not me so
they're laughing
the other person okay is laughing and he
was laughing i'm like
okay are we just gonna like pretend like
it didn't happen are we gonna like laugh
about it
and what happened was the person who was
a grown man
blamed it on me
[Laughter]
no one thought that wasn't you
let me tell you something yeah if i ever
farted in front of you yeah
it would definitely be silent but deadly
never audibly never audibly you know
what i'm saying i'm a lady
you